the holiday we observed monday was once
known as decoration day its origins
dating back to the american civil war
the earliest known observance took place
in charleston south carolina in 1865.
around 250 union soldiers who died in
confederate custody were buried in
unmarked graves to honor them recently
freed black residents of charleston
created a proper burial ground and days
later thousands came to decorate the
graves as we observed this memorial day
we turn to a remarkable portrait of the
harlem hell fighters on display at the
smithsonian art museum in washington
nancy chen talked to the artist behind
the piece
you see these nine
strong beautiful
young men looking like superstars this
is a snapshot of some of the brave men
who made up the
369th infantry regiment of world war one
that are known as the harlem hell
fighters
we visited bisa butler last summer at
her new jersey studio as she stitched
life into her largest portrait quilt
the fabrics carefully chosen to help
tell the story of the soldiers they're
from world war one and they came right
out of harlem
most of them were black and puerto rican
but even in war times the harlem health
fighters couldn't escape racism
segregation prevented them from serving
alongside white u.s soldiers it was the
french who gave them the opportunity to
fight the united states in essence
loaned the soldiers to the french and it
meant a lot for me to be able to portray
not only are these young men fighting
for their country but they fought for
their very dignity as men
the 369th infantry unit spent
191 days on the front lines that's more
time in combat than any other american
unit
their bravery mostly forgotten over a
hundred years later each of the nine
soldiers took a month so this took 11
months in total
but when you look at the piece and you
look at one figure you're seeing a whole
month of my life
put into making sure that every detail
was
accurate it jumps out at you
the dignity of the men they're staring
you right in the eye and compelling you
to see them for their humanity to see
their american patriotism in 1919 the
harlem health fighters came back home to
a victory parade in new york and despite
their bravery and patriotism they still
faced bigotry and discrimination it's a
portrait of these men but it's also a
window
and not just a window into the past but
a window into the soul a window into the
real vision
of who and what
and how african americans want to be
seen in this country
last year the u.s government awarded the
courageous soldiers the congressional
gold medal thank you to this body for
putting aside partisanship and helping
write a centuries-old wrong
it's never too late to do the right
thing it meant a lot for me to have this
piece here at the renwick which is right
next to the white house because it's
reframing where they belong and it's
giving them the acknowledgement that
they should have had for cbs saturday
morning nancy chen new york
a beautiful tribute the harlem
hellfighters portrait quilt as part of
the exhibition this present moment
crafting a better world showcasing over
a hundred artists